okay if you're like me you're always
looking for that perfect steak either at
a restaurant
or at home well one steakhouse certainly
has amazing steaks and today we're
joined by chef patrick munster of one
steakhouse to talk about how to make the
perfect steak at home among other things
how you doing good to have you here
fantastic how about you great i've been
it's funny i've been uh grilling and no
pun intended uh chef patrick here about
how to do a good steak at home because
it's always a mystery to me i've heard a
million different things like everybody
everybody's different right
but
you know if you're going to grill at
home
my
biggest word of advice is build this
two-tier fire you can do it with a gas
grill you can do it with your
charcoal grill have one hot side and one
not so hot side so you sear it initially
sear it get it that good crust on it and
then you finish it off in that not so
hot side and a question i have is i've
heard varying opinions on this do you
let a steak get to room temperature
before you grill it and
like i said everybody's opinions are
different yeah i'm of the philosophy
that you don't you keep it cold
and then you season it really well
and then therefore the inside you have a
little like leeway you're not going to
overcook it if it's already room
temperature what are the best seasonings
for steaks salt and pepper just salt and
pepper i've heard that yeah a good steak
doesn't need all the other stuff a
little bit of oil salt pepper what kind
of oil a little like high smoke point
oil like a canola oil okay yeah no extra
virgin nothing like that yeah you know
and then
you know be interactive with your guests
you know take their temperatures some
people like mid well some people like
rare some people like mid mid-rare you
know
have fun with your guests and make make
your house your own little cool
restaurant love it of course it's easier
if you just go to one steakhouse tell us
about one steakhouse for the folks who
haven't been there so we're in the
virgin hotel
and
you know the virgin did such a great job
with this property they breathed a
little bit of life in the place um it's
lighter it's brighter it's more fun and
the steakhouse is the same way you know
we're
not stuffy at all yeah come in have a
good time drink some good wine
take down one of these bad boys
all of this looks amazing yeah do you
have a few friends with you
yeah yeah
good stuff chef patrick thanks so much
for joining us really appreciate you
being here jillian
now to a story where sure you're going
to